well you know i do a backflip now right
i saw the backflip into the foam pit
like a four-year-old here's the thing
about brian count
he's 53 and brian calm will do 10 back
flips
and no but but
brian kellon's sore oh they're short
from body groups oh yeah different body
type different muscle
yeah yeah um
i do a backflip i'm dehydrated don't
want to pull up the video burn or no you
wrote hard what buddy you only pulled
the video now of him doing the backflip
you know what watch this yeah
you see your son did the same thing
that's my daughter though but you know
what um
she did a front flip but i never thought
i could do it i was just kind of a
chicken
hey you didn't do it it's a backflip no
it's not and that's not even the good
one bring up the good ones
dude until you land it on the ground
that you can't go back well
what about if i landed on the trampoline
no come on
the trampoline that'd be that'd be
pretty cool on a trap but still not like
the ground well let's see where my head
is and see if i'm clearing
i want to know if i'm clearing the pad
let's see if i'm clearing the pad right
so so let's see there's the ground
i don't have i can't jump a lot there so
let's see where i'm where
where my head is will i hit the ground
this is what i'm terrified of
oh you you wouldn't maybe you would have
hit the ground i would if you didn't you
would have hit the ground
well that's dangerous that scares the
[ __ ] out of me is that the good one yeah
dude
hey chin we're all set hey you can't do
a backflip
don't do a backflip on the ground but
you're landing you would have went
face your knees would have hit the
ground in your face
you wouldn't which i'd say cold hard
cash to watch but you're not gonna do it
can you pause it where i'm upside down
to see where my head is
that's what i want to know you guys see
where the legs are for the landing
yeah right no you see
that that's the ground that's that would
be the ground mama well
right there see that's well that's a
problem brandon
that's not backflip no that's not a
backflip because i could i would go
right into the [ __ ] ground there
your neck ah that scares me i need you
quit saying you can do a backflip
i didn't want to have to do this you
have to do this yes chin just slow it
down
you broke your [ __ ] god damn it dude
that just made me nervous
and you sent some of those videos to all
of us he's not doing a backflip
look at that no you you went headfirst
into the cement dude i did
i did i did
now your daughter's close to clearing it
there
the whole thing's a bad idea for a 53
year old at the hole jeff foley said
they're tough
brian there's zero reason for a 53 year
old to do a backflip you have
zero reason for it and you're right
unless you want to be awesome jeff
that's right unless you're gonna be an
awesome 53 year old
yeah she she's sydney who's the [ __ ]
world champion free runner in women's
division said that she taught a 50 an 80
year old man to a backflip
her friend's father really i was like i
don't believe her and i'm gonna do it
i don't believe her i wonder though i
think she was probably meant like into
the foam pit
and you know i said i sent it to you i
said it brandon you're expecting to get
a congratulations and then he goes
it's in the phone it's in the phone
though yeah i was like you know what's
in the phone dude
that was a better one i think oh yeah
well he's first of all one time learning
how to talk
once i learn how to talk it's gonna be
sick can you do a backflip or a front
flip cat
nope when you're a kid you can't i feel
like you'd be good no only cartwheels
even cartwheels are a little challenging
like to do a good cartwheel with your
legs just straight and don't
fold like a scorpion yeah i was always
afraid that's really what it is
yeah you'll be pretty i can't commit to
it yeah yeah well the way you work
you work from there and you put up now
you put a pad there not a
foam pit you know it's all it's a
process
dude keep going every day the thin boy
backflip club guys it's starting
and we're meeting look at you
how fun how fearless was tiger with
tiger island oh he's amazing
he's amazing right now yeah yeah yeah
yeah
watch your tongue oh okay what's gonna
happen
what are you gonna do use some of that
boxing you've been doing
oh she was [ __ ] disrespected